[Music]
so my sense of your support of Trump
please correct me if I'm wrong is not
that you love him or his policies don't
all support well I don't want to go too
far with that word yeah and out there
right and you've said some interesting
things about your support of Hillary so
yeah so correct me if I'm wrong that
it's not that you're necessarily
supporting Trump but you like the
techniques or you at least understand
the techniques that he's using to get
his message across and I think they're
very much in line with some of the
techniques that you just described to me
is that a fair estimation and I'll
backtrack the word support if but let me
put it in my my words yeah put the
context straight here I don't think that
anybody who's about seven years old
should get hired for a job that requires
great mental agility flexibility high
energy and even staying alive which is
very important either I do the job of
the president they keep saying he's high
energy be alive right so so it's hard
for me to get on board either those
choices because really 320 million
people in the United States and the best
we could get is to seventy-year-old
racist yeah or biggest CEO depending
which side you're looking at yeah well
we'll get into this both biggest and
secondly my political views don't really
align closely with either one of them
right but that said what I noticed last
year was Trump had a an influencing or
it influencers tool set he had the
skills of a hypnotist the skills of
persuasion that I immediately said Bing
fairly early on last year and said
that's not normal while he's doing his
technique that people don't understand
he's just a better persuader and so I'm
a big fan of his persuasion talents and
I think people need to understand that
in context of him and maybe not think of
him as the Clay's crazy clown right
there's lots of times there's in tension
there and there's a lot of strategy and
you know he's playing the long game in a
lot of ways yeah
so can you describe that part of it that
you know a lot of people will say well
he's just nuts or he says anything and
it's just all crazy and all that but
what you're saying really is that there
is a method to this madness he's not
just walking up there every day and
saying crazy things with no plan that
there's an actual plan and it's pulling
some of the the tools that you're
talking about
yeah plan might be overstating it
because who knows you know in this kind
of context how far in advance they
really can plan or how much makes sense
but definitely he is saying how can I
control the most energy mm-hmm all right
so persuasion is about making somebody
focus on your thing mm-hmm until they
think it's important because the human
brain is so dumb that it thinks whatever
it pays attention to the most is the
best okay or the worst or the most
important but anyway in their minds it's
priority arises right now as long as he
doesn't you know make too many things
people think he's the worst from the
attention alone is a positive right so
that's basically the the heart of it
right this that it's an attention game
that he's using and that's why it was so
easy to dispatched it's a pretty big
toolbox yeah but if he had to mention
one thing this sort of you know a
shining object and it would be
manipulating attention but he also
manipulates attention away from things
he doesn't want so my best example is
during the first debate a year ago when
the Trump was asked about his comments
about women in the past now this was a
trap that nobody can get out of right
you can't say there's nothing you can
say because now the media has made
people's attention on these bad things
so just focusing on it makes them seem
higher priority mm-hmm and what does
Trump say he goes only Rosie O'Donnell
and suddenly all the energy sucked out
of the question and went to this visual
person who is disliked at least by the
base you know the Republicans could be
counted on to have an extreme reaction
so it's a face whenever you can put a
face to something and personality and a
visual all the energy just sucks into
the room and said that was the moment I
got out of my chair so I wait a minute
this is not normal and then I watch to
see if he could repeat it and he kept
doing it and doing it
yeah and then by the time you was doing
the low-energy the thing I think I was
the first person probably in the country
who said okay that's not a random insult
that's the end of Bush this is dead and
the reason is that his what I call
linguistic kill shots yeah are not just
insults that's what people thought the
first part these are engineered alright
so look at low-energy how engineered
this is right you take something that
hasn't been used before in the political
realm you know it's not the usual thing
you say in politics so therefore you can
imbue it with his own meaning right it's
his own thing then he picks something
that matches the physicality of the
person that's another big trick right
something when you look at him you say
yeah that feels right right now here's
the thing before he said that before he
reframed a bush as being low-energy I
think most people had the same
impression I did I looked at that guy
and I said you know he looks like a calm
seasoned executive he looks like he
would be unruffled right and even a
nuclear war that's exactly the kind of
executive I want running my country and
then that Bush says Low Energy and every
time you look at him after that you go
well it does look a little Low Energy
yeah and you don't even know why that's
bad in the Edit feels sort of bad so now
he's created here's the second the the
other the other part that's important he
creates a trap for a confirmation bias
so that everything that Bush does using
his just normal personality yeah makes
you think oh yeah and it just so his
label reinforces over time same with
lyin Ted Cruz right Ted Cruz
unfortunately has a little bit of a
distrustful face yeah it's just
something that's kind of slimy when
people just have that face right yeah
and because he's a politician he's gonna
say things that aren't true like oh
correct right right but because he got
the tag your confirmation bias will go
to everything he says wait he's lying
he's lying
so is that really the genius of this
that he said lyin Ted Cruz and he calls
her crooked Hillary when there's every
evidence to believe that someone could
call him those things and be just as
truthful if not more truthful than he's
being right because he's taken every
position we can talk about some of the
immigration stuff but he's already
scaling that back it's so well well it's
important to pick the one that people
are already sort of primed to believe or
there's something about his physicality
that would make them easily believe it
Trump there's a lot of things you can
say about him but what Clinton has
finally jumped on that was sort of late
in that in the process because she was
fighting Bernie and that was a different
fight mm-hmm but at this point she's
going with the the racist irrational
racist thing yeah and that too is an
engineered kill shot I believe I'm
reasonably certain that she has
professionals working for one in
particular that I have nicknamed
Godzilla
ghazal is my pet name for rubber chil
Dini who wrote the book influence mm-hmm
who would be considered that the monster
of persuasion if you were going to hire
one person mm-hmm to persuade the world
this is the guy that's the guy okay and
apparently he did consult on Obama's
campaign mm-hmm so it would be it would
be surprising if he had not been asked
at least but I don't have confirmation
that but I do know that Clinton went
from having no persuasion game at all
talking about facts and her experience
and her policies and realizing that that
wasn't going to work yeah and then she
went full Trump this summer and said
forget about all my facts and policies I
mean she's not forgetting them but she's
not emphasizing right you want to be
real scared of this guy okay and here's
the best part
Trump was using fear as a persuasion
technique because fear is the best thing
you can do right you scare people they
have to they have to fix that first
you fix your fear first then you work on
the other stuff so he said look at these
these terrorists coming in look at the
criminals crossing the border look at
the you know the economy falling apart
now whether or not any that's true it
generates fear fear is real good for
persuasion then what did what did
Clinton have she had her of facts and
her experience that's nothing right and
then she ratcheted up and said no the
real fear is Trump right because Trump
is saying maybe you got a fear from a
terrace but if you think about it what
are the odds that a terrorist is going
to kill you right whoa so that fear is
fear they worked but it's not like a
comprehensive fear that gets everybody
then Clinton said if Trump gets in the
office he's going to have his finger on
the nuclear codes and you're all dead
and suddenly she got all kinds of
purchase and you know in her poll
numbers started right I mean she
basically has a commercial out right now
saying exactly that so right so do you
think there was a calculated what does
that say then I guess about the Clinton
campaign that pretty much this all went
down last week like this all seems to
have come to a head last week with the
big speech calling him a racist waking
him - all right and Breitbart and we'll
get into all that do you think there was
really a sit-down where they said man
the technique he's using is really
working and we have to now shift you out
of policy and all that stuff or or was
it just it's sort of low hanging fruit
to call someone racist they're doing it
to each other now it's just
oh you're a racist you're a see it's
become meaningless I think for the most
part the word has become sort of
meaningless what do you think there was
a real calculated sit down like the
technique he's using is working we
better start playing ball this way
they're both doing what I call a a be
testing it's a word from the technology
world where you're testing one technique
and then you measure how well does and
then you test another and if that works
better you go with this one if this one
works better you try yet another one to
see if that's even better do you get the
best one there's no doubt that they
found out their other attacks weren't
working I think there was a WikiLeaks
saying that they they thought attacking
him on his business acumen wasn't
working because people sort of had in
their mind that that he was good at that
stuff whether that's true or not right
show you some bankruptcies but they go
but wait a minute he's still at
buildings everywhere so whether it's
true or not yeah the trouble of the
bankruptcy story is his name is on five
hundred entities and yeah four of them
didn't go well so that's actually more
like a home run than a failure no in an
entrepreneurial sense so yeah I think
that they tested until they found that
there are the racist things the one is
stuck and because of the way he talks is
unfiltered method and the policies that
he's put out they attract confirmation
bias for those watching we don't know
what confirmation bias is it's a
well-known mental phenomena
where if you think something's true you
imagine every bit of evidence to support
that right whether it is not usually
you'll see it that way once you've
decided right by the way that's that's
what the hypnotist learns the heaven it
just learns that once you've decided
which is the rational decision that that
there is no such thing as data and
rationed logic just doesn't exist that
you basically will then just go through
life finding just the things that
validate what you have presupposed way
back way and let me prove that beyond
any doubt yeah
if ration rational thinking logic
existed there would only be one religion
we would all just figure it out there
would be mostly people all on one side
in these in these political events not
every time it's about 5050 right now
what are the odds of that right yeah
like or I asked the question once
where do where'd all the smart people
come out on this like if you polled
only smart people right well educated
really well-informed smart people would
they all have the same opinion no right
no right if there was anything to logic
and data and thinking if thinking were a
real thing like we you know we're really
you know taking the right data and
making the right decisions people would
mostly be on the receive side and these
political questions you know even if
it's 75 25 it would be overwhelmingly
you know on one side but or not so as
someone that cares about thinking and
critical thought being smart and all of
that stuff
this has to be a little depressing for
you right I mean as you already said the
70 year old part and all that we've only
selected just these two but just the
general discourse has to be kind of
depressing right absolutely not because
remember since since my 20 is when I
learned hypnosis I've abandoned the idea
that anyone is rational including me so
once you abandon that the world becomes
far less frustrating not more so look at
the world that the rest of you are
living in yeah and I feel sorry for you
bastards I've been living in this world
because you're looking at the people who
are on the other side of a political
debate and you're saying why can't they
see the logic the rational arguments
that are so cleared
and the answer is always the same you're
an idiot
yeah yeah but guess what they're
thinking they are - yeah and yeah
they're having exactly the same thought
with their set of confirmation bias and
they're so sure that they're right
special so basically you're saying you
Scott Adams don't have any of the
answers right but you're just saying
this is this is the game so we have to
deal with it in that reality well I have
all the answers if you're talking about
the political stuff you got all the wins
we haven't gotten to that yeah well
let's get to let's go you wait before we
get to all the answers that'll be a
better thing to probably end with all
the answers to everything
maybe we'll wrap up the show I could end
the show if we get all the answers yeah
we'll see but I'm curious so the racist
word we've talked about it a lot on this
show that one of my issues has been how
the the left has used the words of
bigotry and racism and homophobia and
all these things they've used them so
much to smear their opponents that these
words have no longer have any meaning
really totally disagree really yeah
racist
never loses its power even now cuz I my
feeling was absolutely both were firing
at each other and it didn't feel like it
took anymore oh no it's taken yeah it's
taking big time yeah if you talk to the
average Clinton supporter about what
they think of Trump and this is
something I've not seen in any other
election you'll see the person who
dislikes Trump physically shake yeah
I've seen people talk about him and
their handshake like there's a lot of
people I mean this is not just a few
observation it's common the people will
spit and yell and shake and that's
because the racist claim sticks it's not
because I think his policies aren't as
good
they prefer this approach as nothing to
do that they think is actually a racist
they've literally been convincing so
that's that subset of Clinton supporters
my suspicion though is that the average
person out there hears the word racist
sees the way these things have been
overused and the way we label everybody
and goes ah it actually in a way
especially if you take the Trump
supporters every time you call them a
racist it actually they like it because
they feel like you've lost the argument
so that's the word you're throwing out
there
there's confirmation bias in in in
action oh I guess that's the best
example yeah someone calls you saying
bad you go so the the Trump supporters
believe is they're not racist or you
know it's not a problem and so they they
imagine the world in which those insults
are ineffective but they are totally
effective it's the strongest sauce you
could possibly put on this spaghetti
mm-hmm terrible analogy yes so this is
the reason Clinton's using it and I'm
sure they've tested everything else and
found out wow this is super yeah let me
get back to the confirmation bias yeah
so look at the charge and look at all
the things that Trump is accused of and
we'll just pick any one and of the bunch
let's take the judge curial thing where
he said that the judge couldn't be
biased because in in Trump's words he
was Mexican now you hear that and even
to my ears that's like mmm yeah the
judge would be biased that couldn't be
biased right right right okay um so even
to my ears that's like oh that's like a
little red flag there
well you back it up if you talk to
someone who is born in this country and
their parents came from Mexico what do
they call themselves well they're
Americans obviously they call themselves
Americans but in casual conversation
they'd say I'm Mexican same way if
you're Italian blood but you you're two
generations away from you know Italy
mm-hmm people still say yeah I'm Italian
it's in understood you're also American
right was we just happen so usually use
the language the way people use language
right so so far he's not a racist he
just used the language like people do
but he went further he said that because
of that you would be biased now you know
who's biased every person well
every person in the world is biased
right no such thing is the unbiased
person there's a reason that that jury's
pick that lawyers kick people off of
juries because of their experience that
is biased there's a reason that a judge
can recuse himself or herself because
they know they're biased and so to
imagine that someone who has let's say
Mexican heritage and presumably the
relatives are Mexican maybe has maybe
he's visited Mexico I don't know if
that's true but it's very
he's got a family influence what is more
influential on your decision-making than
your family and how you have to live
with them for the rest of your life
imagine this judge ruling inexplicably
favorably for Trump and then attending
insect's family reunion right now remove
Mexican it doesn't matter who it is if
this guy's if this guy does something
that's unpopular with his family that's
a problem that's the perfect setup for a
human forget that he's a judge forget
Diaz heritage any human in that
situation is almost guaranteed to be
biased now the question is is a
professional judge can he see past that
that's his job right of course right but
it's still smart for Trump to put that
out there because he's persuading all
right here it's a legal case right and
both both sides are trying to persuade
as hard as they can
so Trump is putting it out there says
hey you know and he's also persuading
the public in advance if I get a bad
judgment I'm going to say people in this
situation can be biased if I get a good
judgment I'm happy I go away
so wrestle he's not doing it as subtly
as you just laid out saying well this
guy might be biased in a calm you know
the way you calmly laid it out he goes
to the easier but that way you're saying
that's the hope that's why he gets
attached the whole point yeah he gets
attention so it's the attention on it
that makes it powerful
mm-hmm so if you were to pick this apart
as a legal strategy and pick the actual
words there actually isn't any racism
there it is a comment about somebody who
has a race in this case not has a
cultural heritage yeah better word yeah
but everybody is influenced by all their
all of their influences right right
their family influences their job they
worked at their pack their background
all that right I suppose the inherent
problem with it in that case is that had
this judge been white of Irish descent
or Italian descent or some other
European descent you acknowledge he
would have certain biases but Trump
would have never figured out a way to
bring up his ethnic background on that
let me let me give you your example
right back to you let's say
is doing some business in Scotland which
he is let's say the people in Scotland
got really mad at him and formed a
partition and the people in Scotland
just hated him yeah I think they're
doing this over that golf course alright
so let's say there was a you know a
second generation Scottish judge I think
even Trump has some Scottish blood yeah
I think so in their case if a Scottish
judge went Scottish parents was involved
and he knew that the Scottish parents
living in Scotland were really really
mad at Trump yeah would it be fair to
say that the Scottish judge who was
really an American citizen with Scottish
background could be biased I think so I
mean wouldn't you right is that a
reasonable yeah so basically you're just
all you're doing really is just peeling
back the you're showing the the wizard
behind the curtain here so more than
anything else you're right you're not
you're not defending the specifics of
what he's doing oh no in this in this
case what I'm doing is giving the
listeners an example of what
confirmation bias looks like yeah when
if you heard the judge curial comment
and of context it does sound like a
racist statement once you put it in its
proper context that goes away and that's
how confirmation bias looks it looks
just like that yeah
do you blame I don't sense you have a
lot of blame in general but do you
prescribe the the symptom of Trump to
just everything that is transpired over
the last 20 years just our terrible
media that doesn't challenge politicians
our discourse that's crumbled to the
point of just yelling racism at
everybody our politicians who lie I
don't think Trump is any bigger bigger
of a liar than Hillary is I think she's
probably a bigger liar everything being
equal but he lies in more of a more of a
regular person way and that makes people
freak out she lies in more of a politic
like it just all led up to him in a way
it seems kind of obvious well you know
we don't live in a single variable world
so you needed everything to be the way
it is plus Trump again the result you
have you can't you can't remove one of
the important variables and there are
lots of them but I think the key
variable and this is what I've been
saying is
skill is skill at persuasion that is the
story I don't think you could take a non
Trump put them in the same world in 2016
and say the world is crazy in the media
is this I don't think you could drop
Kanye West into there yet although I've
said he does have some really high
persuasion skills but he doesn't have
some of the other stuff so yeah I think
it's a trump specific phenomenon yeah so
all right so I don't sense full Trump
support correct is that
well you're not us support no I would
never never support the use of support
interns and yet at the same time I think
a lot of people think you're like one of
the biggest Trump supporters out there
and it's really just because you're
talking about his technique well I'm an
admirer of his technical yeah I unlike
many people am very amused by his humor
and his personality and by the way
before we're filming you mentioned you
have a New York background as do I from
upstate New York and I haven't talked to
too many New York people about this I'm
going to run this by you the goddess
thought I went to SUNY Binghamton by the
way that was another piece of mind you I
was at Hardwick is that right oh my god
we're we're practically neighbors there
you go the wrong times um what was I
talking about upstate New York oh yeah
so when Trump talks in these ways that
offend the world mm-hmm I as a New
Yorker say that's not offensive talk
that's just talk yeah that's not yeah
that's just how I talk one of the one of
the things I had to learn to change when
I moved to California is that when I
talked like New York people talk up
state or city mm-hmm it's there's a
bluntness that is offensive yeah and I
had to really work on that also there's
an arrogance or perceived arrogance of
New Yorkers because we talk honestly
about things were good at we also talk
honestly about the things we're bad at
but that kinda gets lost in California
right you know it's like oh you have a
big ego no I said I'm good at these
things I'm just like you right just like
everybody we're all good at something
were bad at something
how is that that was that terrible
but the things that New Yorkers do is
they say man I want to punch that gun
and those Heaney's I've you need two
bullets in the back of the head you know
I'll give him two in the chest one in
the head it's just normal New York talk
yeah
but you see that at a context and by the
way I think this is purely a trump
mistake meaning that there's I don't
think there's somebody telling him
wait this stuff doesn't sound the same
as soon as you leave the history as soon
as you leave your state right really
doesn't sound the same yeah it's funny
because I was just tell you I was I
visited New York for the last ten days I
got back yesterday and even though I
lived there my whole life one of the
things that I really noticed about being
in New York City for for ten days was
the incredible you know racial mix and
every type of person on earth is in that
city on subways together we're not
killing each other we're pretty much
just ignoring each other because
everyone's going to live their lives and
I thought there's something actually
beautiful about that it doesn't matter
ultimately if keep these people
privately hate each other for racist
reasons or anything but they're all out
there living their lives that's not to
say there isn't any crime or any you
know bad racism or something like that
but I thought that was actually
inspiring about New York that we're told
we live in a society that's so afraid
and everything and yet our best city has
everybody and we're doing it that I love
that example and to that point I'm gonna
steal something that I heard dr. Laura
say once so I I'm kind of you know maybe
modifying the words a little bit but
I'll credit for the thought and the
thought is that you are what you do
you're not what you think because if we
were judged by our thoughts we would all
be executed yeah you know you should be
killed for just the things you're
thinking right that's coming yeah you
are what you do and more importantly you
are what you do recently because if I'm
judged by my past I got some problems if
you're judged by your past you've
probably got some problems too we were
all in her 20s ones right it's all it's
all bad stuff in the past yeah the goal
of life is to improve so if we're not if
we're not improving we got a problem
right I think both Clinton and Trump
have probably improved and I think that
judging them either one
them by something that happens say 10 or
more years ago is is probably a bad bet
because we're all bad people 10 years
ago compared to how we are now because
ideally we're all getting better smarter
better informed well the hope is but a
lot but people do obviously go the other
way too
so when people are judging for example a
Trump for his let's say his recent focus
on african-americans and say that's in
his mind he's now thinking that mm-hmm
I say you're on the wrong page what can
work what counts is what he's doing and
what he was doing before wasn't as good
because he wasn't mentioning you know
other groups in society and now he is so
he's going from less good to good
if doing the right thing doesn't count
anymore what the right I mean so
that that's really fascinating so when
they when they take something like the
immigration thing where he said we're
gonna kick them all out day one then he
tempered it this past week and then it
sounds like he untempered it by saying
you know first hour in office it's gonna
start or something those are all crazy
comments like we're not getting rid of
everybody then the tempering actually I
thought sounded somewhat sane and then
I'm gonna do it in the first hour sounds
completely insane but at that point is
there what that's not crazy at all no
absolutely no I get it he's using the
tools you're talking about but is there
so I understand that but is there
anything that he could say do you think
that would turn off his people because
he immigration was their number one
thing and he pretty much I mean even Ann
Coulter was acknowledging it like he
backed off that because he was trying I
think to become better to become a more
legitimate candidate yeah so he had to
throw them under the bus um well people
who believed it I would I would put it
in these terms in hypnosis there's
something called pacing and leading
pacing is when you match your subject in
any way you match the breathing the way
they talk the way their their posture
because if you do that long enough
people get comfortable with you and then
you can do what's called leading so then
you then you can do something different
and then people will start doing the
thing that you're doing so you start by
copying them until they learn to copy
you subconsciously
they're not do
intentionally it's a it's a major it's
one of the biggest components of
hypnosis is that idea what Trump is
doing is pacing and leading the entire
Republican Party what you think he's
doing is that he's gone in and his ideas
are a little different and somehow with
his you know he's punched his way
through the top that is not what he's
doing he hollowed out the GOP and he's
wearing it as a skin when he's done the
Republican Party will never be the same
yeah he has changed it and he has
improved it he got in front he got on
stage at the you know Republican
convention and did a full-throated
what I thought was completely sincere
endorsement of doing more to help the
lbgtq community
Peter Thiel spoke he meant it and what
happened with all the Republicans as
soon as soon as he did that you don't
hear anybody complaining about that
right
yeah not that they would have complained
necessarily but the Republican Party
changed Trump changed them and they
can't go back he pasted them until he
led them and on immigration he pasted
them he said what they needed to hear
until they said Trump Trump Trump he's
our guy I feel good with you now he's in
a position to lead all right the
Republic rat excited they were already
there you know they wanted something
kinder and gentler and by the way so do
I I want this to be dealt with in the
most humane way that also makes sense
for the country but he's it's a little
bit like but slightly different than
Nixon goes to China you know Nixon was a
hard-ass about China so when he went
there people believed him that he wasn't
just selling out he was still Nixon
people believe that Trump is still Trump
and if he sold them that he had their
interests in mind which he totally did
right for his Republican base he said I
hear you about this immigration I'm
gonna make it my top priority he pasted
them they trusted him they got in his
side now Trump and nobody else can
soften that position no one else is in
that position because of the way he did
it
but it looks to the public like it's a
flip-flop it's the opposite it's it's
I'm sure it was intentional for Lou
being a
right so you would say that you know I
saw a lot of people that after Peter
teal spoke and Trump had that nice
moment actually where he he said the
thing about LGBT Americans and he got it
I what I think was a pretty spontaneous
applause break from the crowd around
base Republicans right um you know I saw
that a lot of people after that were
saying well still look what's in the
party platform and there's still stuff
that's not great on marriage equality
few things but you would argue that's
basically irrelevant at this point
because he's the he's the head he's the
leader and he's made the acknowledgement
so well they well they're not done I
mean there's you know everything's a
work in progress right but I think
Trump's support of the LGBT you lose on
whatever a bunch of ladders community
was both sincere and a higher priority
than the wedding cakes and guess what I
think the wedding cakes will be awful
okay and the weddings yeah I think the
Republican Party will we'll catch up in
essence so is that the irony the
ultimate irony of Trump more than
anything else is that while these people
get shaky when you're talking to them
and angry and stammering and sweaty and
all that stuff that he actually became
the Republican nominee by basically
being Pro gay marriage he's not gonna
try to flip gay marriage he's for you
know gay people to live equally
basically and at the same time he's been
running anti-war he certainly doesn't
want a nation bill that's pretty obvious
he wants people that were giving things
to to pay us all of that stuff so he
actually sort of killed the neocon part
of it and killed the Christian
conservatives like he slayed them both
on the way so he but he should have
become the left's favorite Republican in
a bizarre way um and maybe still will I
mean I'm still predicting that he'll win
in the landslide I know the polls don't
look like that right now but they're
tightening as we're talking how much of
that do you think is just that there's a
certain fear of saying you're for Trump
dokie probably all properly probably a
lot of it I know a lot of people who say
they're that they won't say out loud
that they support Trump because since I
said that I support Hillary Clinton for
my personal safety yeah I want to get
that yeah because I live in California
where that's kind of important uh I've
heard from people who say the same thing
say oh my god I can't say it at work I
can't say it to my family we can't say
it to my friends mmm how many there are
is the great mystery but I don't think
they're being picked up in polling
necessarily
[Music]